nous sommes à alti un village dans la
région de Kiev
le 20 mars 2022 l'armée russe est entrée
ici
occupant la commune pendant une dizaine
de jours laissant des stigmates visibles
un peu partout mais aussi des blessures
bien plus difficiles à repérer
dans le noir alors que des femmes
attendent de passer des examens médicaux
les associations en profitent pour
tenter de recueillir la parole des
femmes
lors de ces entretiens Irina tente
également de repérer les femmes victimes
de violences sexuelles ou à minima de
faire passer le mot afin qu'elle se
manifeste d'elle-même
Vasile chef du centre régional d'aide
sociale et psychologique de Kiev va
directement au contact des habitants
pour enquêter sur les violences
sexuelles et sensibiliser la population
mais il affirme que 95% des appels reçus
viennent d'ukrainien qui ont tout
simplement besoin de parler
sous l'égide de l'organisation
internationale women for women vas-y les
Irina aident actuellement 33 femmes sur
les 1500 qu'ils ont accompagnés depuis
août
si l'objectif de ces psychologues est de
documenter les crimes sexuelles ces
équipes ne laissent jamais tomber celles
et ceux qui leur demandent de l'aide les
polytraumatismes laissées par des mois
d'occupation et un an de guerre à grande
échelle sont déjà une question
essentielle pour la société ukrainienne
et voilà pour ce document